[Music]
the Carolina Reaper it's spicy it's
spicy welcome the hot ones all right
it's the most spicy am I right I thought
the ghost pepper was or no I think
Carolina Reaper has the most skille or
whatever I bet at that point it's the
same [__] thing you know yeah we we
ate both did you eat that chip you
YouTubers weal we talked about the one
they took it off right and somebody died
from somebody died oh yeah but but time
he really he died from being a [__] oh
[__] would you die from being salot hot
cuz other people ate it completely out
this dude his name is Mike Jack okay
Mike Jack this guy's a legend legend oh
[__] what is that Stu that's Tomy 50
Carolina Reaper Chili Peppers he's got
gloves on but he's not worried about
putting that in his body he's a legend
dude your fingers are burn hot oh my
[__] god he's just eating peppers by
itself are raw raw Carolina Reaper
pepper holy smokes it has it's the
current record for the hottest [__]
pepper by
schille why
would [__] [__] out it's going to
dude he says it's like the first couple
are intense for him even too cuz he's
used to it but he's like once you get a
rhythm going you just keep putting them
down cuz it's also also once you get a
rhythm going more of the pepper touches
more areas of your mouth so it gets more
unbearable at the same time but there's
got to be a limit where just is numb
right so check out he's got the new
record for the fastest time to eat 50
Carolina Reaper Chili Peppers it's 6
minutes and 49.2 seconds is he alive he
is he is alive but the thing is once he
beat that record he ventually went on to
keep cuz he's already in session to keep
eating and he ate a total of 135 peppers
in one city Jesus oh my right he really
trying to secure that bag what does he
what what bag does he get that kind of
stuff the record never like like
interested me does he have any sperm
left something got to [__] up something
any challenges challenges maybe but
spice challenge he's actually he's
actually still number two in most most
attempts in one city number two he beat
the record for 50 in the first one to 50
yeah but he's number two for the league
of fire Reaper challenge leaderboard
which tracks attempts to eat the most of
the peppers in a single City W okay Nick
question does he have any sperm left
I wouldn't asked that of course the
answer is no I don't think you going to
have kids that's why bro the next week
had to be there's no way it doesn't hurt
I think intine surgery yeah it's got it
no he said he CED to it it hurts his
stomach big time yeah he says the
initial shock of spiciness is intense
the second one doesn't seem as bad but
each one after that gets hotter and
hotter as the peppers touch new places
in your mouth I'm really just curious
more about like the aftermath he says I
get bad cramps it feels like someone is
squeezing and twisting my guts oh your
mind is telling you to stop but you have
to convince yourself to keep pushing
through you don't have to convince
yourself that's the thing like it's cool
it's cool to be the David goggin of like
of like spicy stuff but then again
afterwards it's like just do something
else do you guys know I got a mouth on
me right and I I talk [__] yep so I have
a neighbor my neighbor Ryan he's like
he's like uh oh you like spicy stuff I'm
like yeah dude yeah yeah and he's like
oh cool I'll make you spicy wings and
then every time I go to his house I'm
like you make little [__] [__] ass
Wings it's not spicy enough for [__]
dude for little [__] I'm like oh it
tastes like [__] again thanks I do also
like that though do you like spicy wings
yeah
[__] hey me too hey you guys are boys
so check it out so so then he gets so
like he's like I'm going to get this guy
right so he buys like one of the hot
ones things like the last dab or
whatever one of the hot on stinks and
then he puts it all over these wings
that he makes just for me we're going to
watch like th he doesn't eat them with
you well no he's going to okay kind of
so so he makes it for Thursday Night
Football this is like a year ago and
then Nikki has a friend over who's like
a really famous poker player chick and
she's like oh [__] I love hot wings and
then my buddy Ryan's like ah yeah these
are different though these are really
hot wings and then like I'm trying to
[__] Steve over basically and she's like
no I love Hot Wings it's great and then
she like eats it and she immediately is
like and she runs to the bathroom and
vomits oh wow that's the kind of [__]
that we're dealing with here
then and you get off on that you like
that oh dude so then Nikki's like
Nikki's like
vlogging right to to see me eat These
Wings and I'm eating the wings and I eat
like six of them and I'm talking [__]
the whole time talking [__] it's
whatever whatever this even tingle a
little bit for you it's a beautiful
dance are you just like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's a beautiful Dance
I'm like a pain [__] in my mouth I love
this [__] I mean you like Thai Spice
that's pretty spicy I like the real deal
yeah so then but then
my body can't deny what's happening
can't deny the
truth so then I disappear during
Thursday Night Football unlike me most
unlike me of all time I'm upstairs
[__] my [__] lower intestine just
wrecking your boys back oh no it's my
it's my house oh okay does that usually
not your home but dude guess what the
guest room is like should be
condemned when I the AC off the guest
bathroom guest bathroom yeah oh man I
had to replace the toilet do you usually
have [__] issues when you do spice cuz
you do big time spice I don't but this
one was like your T can handle it it was
that fast though like when is your 30
minutes away 30 minutes [__] novelty
hot sauce 30 minutes novelty hot
sauce anymore but delicious too did you
did you know that people that have high
testosterone likes a lot of spice yeah
of course it I must be lowy yeah me too
bro say I I'm [__] super good average
200 200 te my mouth can take it but I
swear to God when I took like when I
turned like 28 I would feel that
stabbing in my stomach so like I can I
like the taste of hot wing maybe not
that extreme but like a nice hot wing
but I like one time it happened and my
stomach hurt so bad I thought I was sick
I didn't even connect it to the wings
and then like 3 months later I had
something else spicy I was like oh no
it's this spicy [__] like out of nowhere
just literally like I'm you know giving
birth or some [__] what's your tolerance
what's your what's your like now I just
skip it all cuz my stomach hurts so bad
what's what about like Takis I'll eat
them like a Taki won't send me the
[__] but like God U like a if you go
to a mom and pop Hot Wing Spot and they
have like a mild medium hot extra even
the hot will probably mess up my stomach
you're a p have you have you mouth could
take it have you had Sichuan spice I
don't know it's a little different it's
numbing yeah even still it's just my
stomach like again I could eat it I just
try not to [__] my brains out anymore
yeah that's what I worry about I don't
do that either dude I like spice but
then do you [__] your brain out or no
you know I don't think I've noticed in
the past and I probably did but now I do
I mean you guys might as well do a
little hot ones here one
day I'm down but like we got to be ready
for like the stomach um we only have two
bathro got be like the last can we just
do like medium ones right yeah or you do
the first five you do the first five
medium ones I've talk too much [__] this
is what I get I deserve it I haven't
talked [__] so I feel like medium On's
is solid for me yeah you do the first
five put a little B Cayenne or something
I'll go like halfway to what your final
is going to be I'll do the most thing
but I'm just saying you got to give me a
day or something I got to like so
pooping well yeah cuz like I have my
luggage here cuz I'm taking off tonight
oh yeah I can't be taking off tonight oh
yeah yeah airplane [__] we potties and
put out I can't walk through LAX like
10,500 steps yeah you do it at Airbnb
maybe you guys do like a group shoot
there I don't know there's going to be a
John I don't know yeah John's a white
way of seeing bathroom I think an Airbnb
would have a John no but we need like
two bedrooms and seven bathrooms maybe a
hotel we need more Johns Than People
John also white people could mean
anything could also mean yeah well if
you're from Pennsylvania it means
anything right do also mean John just
means the toilet no people from
Philadelphia say John for everything
like hand me that John really you never
heard that yeah what's that John I'm not
from phel like that thing they use it
for thing whatever wouldn't that be
annoying as [__] to be named John yeah
kind of maybe no one you guys never
heard that yeah I think it's mostly
Philly but a lot of Pennsylvania say
yeah pass that
a lot of Chinese people drop the N bomb
when they don't say the N bom the you
don't know about the yers you don't know
[__] about
Philadelphia you don't know about the
yers dude no [__] about Philadelphia I
don't know [__] about Philadelphia I
just know John's and I know Herz is
having a pretty hurt scene yers is is
what you call philadelphians BR is that
where hurts the the car in a place comes
from the word hurts that's just a random
quarterback at this point I just dunked
on you br I don't know insert put the
[__] backboard on your head
dude he's so scared of Halo he's been
scared of Halo all day plasma grenade
I'm not even scared scared you're stuck
been scared of Halo for the last hour oh
me and my Elite controller me and my
Elite controller he's so scared I can't
I can't lose I have those [__] little
p hand works now you're [__] I can't you
take a nap your right hand don't work
disclaimer in case these videos don't go
in
order his ass at Halo somebody's scared
of Halo here and I feel like we're going
to set up this battle bro I would love a
little land hillo we need to see who's
going to win let's do party dude all
right be insane party L party hot ones
or medium ones for most of us bro just a
dude sleepover dude let's go hot [__]
let do it and we all wear oversized
Uncle chin shirts would you back out you
got to spend quality time with your wife
you guys planned the dinner right before
I left GE notice yeah give me a couple
days notice and I'll I'll how you the
most busiest person in the
world I don't know Nick's busier than
the president of the United States it's
just it's just the time of my life right
now dude I have two kids at home you
guys we have multiple companies and we
still have time to do dinner with each
other T you know he only has one kid I
have two kids bring the dogs to the
sleepover yeah dude hey we missed you at
dinner last night dude it was really fun
well I I wish I could have gone but you
guys planned it you guys planned it
[__] right then and there there was a
lot of bonding that went on I know this
guy was telling me about it he was like
next time you need to come to the
[__] meetings that we have and I was
like all right dude sorry I do not sound
like he's like Steve Steve's only here
once a month we need have a [__]
meeting I did say that no excus and and
on top of that
we went to Thai food because that day
Bart was like we need to get Thai food
and get trash and just go slide it ins
was good Bart said take the whole
country and like Dr it to recycling bit
and then hit
[Music]
delete